why women know man we gotta trust white
women believe all women bro
you have to believe all this is women
this if there's one thing that we learn
from this weekend
is believe all women you know what we
should have learned it earlier
say again we should have learned it
earlier we should have learned it
earlier this is just confirming what we
should have already known why are we
letting black people into the park
oh my god why are we doing it guys we
know what could happen right we
know like thank god there are these
white women out there
protecting the parkour protecting the
park like you don't need those park
rangers you don't need park officials
you need white women
honestly give them a little goofy ass
hat white women should have all the
power
white women should have all it's clear
they know what to do you know what to do
they don't abuse it how many people got
raped that day
not her not her that's why i'm telling
you that much stop doing it more or less
one less negative one rapes real talk
wait a minute what what how'd it become
negative because it would have been one
if she didn't so that's zero if she
didn't do her civic duty
i think one minus one is zero no that's
negative
how you get negative rapes it didn't go
in here
so that's zero [ __ ] i don't want to
listen to this magic thing
this is not a math debate the focus is
that we gotta believe all women we gotta
believe all the way i apologize i'd like
to apologize
because i've said some chauvinistic
things i've said some chauvinistic
things bro
i've said some chauvinistic things on
this podcast and
i really would like to say i apologize
to all women and from now on i'm gonna
believe you all no matter what you say
all the time no matter what you say i
believe you all the time
that's it i cheated on you in your dream
congratulations to you my friend look at
that white woman you're with
god
[Applause]
[ __ ] behind you going yeah son i'm with
my girl but
yo for real that white woman's amazing
isn't she telling the truth
he's with his black girl for like no oh
no but that she's high level
that's a high level white woman right
there that white woman is that is
man oh man oh man
black women get mad at that but that is
top shelf white woman right there
you know how you can tell how pretty a
white woman is
the value you look at her and then you
wonder how long they would look for if
she was missing
come on take a look take a look look at
this
i saw you look mad sweetie how long if
he was missing how long do you think
they were
how long did they do exactly she don't
even she went
you know the deal i ain't saying nothing
wrong white woman's life is valuable
what's his name jordan uh vandersloot
right we find out he was a serial killer
man he kills women
that's what he do he do it well you know
what i mean we know the girl that he
that he
you know supposedly had uh what's girl
in aruba
natalie holloway right but the one he
just killed a girl in peru what's her
name um
exactly
[Applause]
look up as you said now you said natalie
natalie
holloway that angel
y'all said that like family feud all
right name a white girl been missing for
five years in the room
name a peruvian girl that was killed
yesterday
what is that big head third world
peruvian bitch's name
it has to be yodis or something goofy
don't get mad at yourself i gave it to
you you saw how fast you said natalie
holloway
diana ross right here said nah she knew
her name
that white guy with natalie holloway
man you called yourself uh whoa
god bless you man that is high level
right then don't be ashamed of it
gorgeous
she mad as hell [ __ ] that white [ __ ]
you know come on
come on ain't nobody looking for you
i might look for you but the news ain't
you
you think fox is reporting you're
missing let's be honest
nancy grace she leads story on nancy
grace for the next six months
i look at that because she's mad as hell
but we don't like that [ __ ] but it is
what it is let's be
i'm gonna be like that let's just let's
be honest that little girl that went
missing um
she was sailing little girl was saying i
forgot damn it but she was she went
sailing went missing
in the indian ocean okay and
they spent good lord her mass broke and
she was floating around
and she gave out her little signal her
beacon they looked for they spent 500
000
like tax money to search for her now
that's my daughter i want that to happen
too but but
if you go sailing
let's be honest how long you think they
gonna spend five come on
remember hey remember football players
in miami went missing
they went sailing they looked for them
for eight
minutes maybe they just sent somebody at
the edge of the beach
[Applause]
i don't i don't see him
we have to call off the search because
it's too much sun uh
the sun the conditions are abnormally
difficult
if i go sailing i'm taking a white baby
on a keychain with me
if my boat go down they gonna find me
i'm gonna have it hook right to the side
of my belt
and i'ma dress the baby real white too
i'm gonna uh put sweatpants on it and
a pair of ugg boots and i'm gonna
take a picture look at this white baby
you don't come get me this white baby
going down with me
see everybody think a sister is the
strongest [ __ ] woman on earth
to an extent that is true but at least a
sister let you know up front
i will kill you white women just the
opposite they play
victim yeah white men were like look at
here
get it in line okay dear
everything's fine there she get on the
phone
hello officer but that white man got a
line for you white women
see when that white man get mad he get
mad
you know brothers we get mad we march we
shall overcome
you know we get a good march in misspell
signs we go here
that white man get mad he snapped you
know white women like i'm taking the
kids i'm taking the house
we're gone we're out of here you [ __ ]
that white man be like this i came from
a long line of brook shires
you're not going to take my seed from me
gwynevere
now here's the one sentence that white
man got for theirs
over my dead body
[Applause]
and that [ __ ] mean that [ __ ]
over my dead body
i'll kill you then i'll kill the kids
i'll burn the [ __ ] house to the
ground then i'll do myself
brother can't even try that [ __ ]
supposed to be like i'm leaving
i'm gonna kill you you killing who let
them kill him again [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] let's get some killing gone
what what [ __ ] be like i'm just playing
girl he's a player
you know i'm joking with you girls you
know i'm joking with you
you don't even get to the part of
burning the house down the kids
they always try to make it like
everybody's after the white woman you
look at the movies
king kong after the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] kong got that white
[ __ ] [ __ ] picked up just blowing on
the whole
i got my white [ __ ]
they took his white [ __ ] that
[ __ ] swam to new york
they took the bishop on a building
where's my white [ __ ]
i need my wife
[Applause]
i am it's very uh exciting to be doing
stand-up
outside of my own country yeah no not
because of you
that's how it's become [ __ ] us
everything's so goddamn
every [ __ ] joke you tell what did you
mean about that
i didn't go to the gym today are you
calling me fat
i feel [ __ ] triggered
gotta [ __ ] apologize to everybody
this is how screwed up my country is
right now
do you you know you know brian cranston
right
that dude did a movie he played a
quadriplegic
and people gave him [ __ ] be like
why is there an able-bodied person
playing a quadriplegic
it's like it's because it's called
acting you're dumb [ __ ]
see if he was a quadriplegic playing a
quadriplegic
that's not acting there's just [ __ ]
laying there
saying [ __ ] that someone else wrote
so tell us what what did you do to
prepare for the role
well i dove head first into the shallow
end of a pool when i was 23.
i feel like i've been preparing for this
role for my whole life
right what is up next for you oh well
they're gonna do a reboot of top gun
uh i'm gonna fly with my prog uh
the co-pilot's gonna be transgendered so
everybody will be happy
she won't die her discarded dick will
block her head
from the canopy there'll be a gender
neutral bathroom on the plane
how [ __ ] dumb is that that's
literally like watching a movie why
didn't you have a murderer
play a murderer and how come the guy he
shot i saw him in another movie
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on
no i don't know what it is i don't know
what it is i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on but i think white women
started it
ah it's the worst
the [ __ ] worst that's all they do is
[ __ ] mother and complain i had no idea
how difficult it was to be a white woman
in the united states of america
evidently
it's really difficult
yeah they're always bitching do you have
any idea what it's like to be me
well i imagine it would be slightly less
awesome than my life
what happened to you today sweetheart
did they not chill your rose
you know was the trolley not running
down at the mall what
happened no it's unreal i'm really
[ __ ] annoyed how white women have the
[ __ ] balls
to throw my white privilege in my face
you know
started to separate themselves from
these white males with their white male
privileges like [ __ ]
you're sitting in a jacuzzi with me what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah put your [ __ ] whining
look there's a little caveat here so you
don't think i'm a complete [ __ ]
right out of the gate all right if
you're [ __ ] if you live in some honey
boo boo lifestyle
on the appalachian trail you know your
uncle just banged you in the dirt all
right
i can listen to you
now one of my fantasies is i want to
drive by like a woman's rally
and just say the most sexist [ __ ] i can
think of
just to watch them lose their minds and
i'll just drive by real slow like yeah
why don't you get back in the kitchen
where you belong
just to look in the rearview mirror
watching him
flipping out on the road spinning around
like
leatherface at the end of texas chainsaw
massacre like